the White House is also expressing
concern about threats posed by Russia
and China President Trump unveiled his
national security strategy yesterday he
said both nations are revisionist powers
must be confronted we also face rival
powers Russia and China that seek to
challenge American influence values and
wealth we will attempt to build a great
partnership with those and other
countries but in a manner that always
protects our national interest
Lieutenant General HR McMaster is the
president's national security adviser he
helped in crafting this document he
joins us now from the White House
general good morning thank you so much
for joining us
good morning his pleasure to be with you
thank you let me just ask you about a
bit of news this morning North Korea has
rejected Secretary of State's Rex
Tillerson proposal for talks without
preconditions
does that mean the military option is
the only one left no what we're doing is
is really applying maximum pressure to
North Korea to convince Kim jong-un that
this is a dead end this pursuit of of
nuclear weapons and an intercontinental
ballistic missile long-range ballistic
missile which of course poses a grave
danger to the whole world so what you've
seen is an effort led by the president
worldwide really though to to isolate
that regime to cut off not just what is
restricted by the current national court
UN Security Council resolutions but to
do more the president has asked all
nations to cut off all trade with this
rogue regime which you see has never met
a weapon it didn't use or proliferate or
or sell to somebody else you saw that
with the cyberattacks you just discussed
and and now you saw with them the murder
of Kim jong-un's brother in a public
airport with a band and nerve agent yes
this is a this is a regime that just
can't get the the this this destructive
capability one of the things that I've
noticed is the president spoke with
Russian President Putin several times in
the last couple of weeks and yet Russia
has increased its trade and it's oil
experts to North Korea did the president
specifically ask Putin to stop that
yes the President did ask President
Putin to do more he wants all nations to
do more and it just doesn't make sense
that Russia would increase trade and
alleviate any pressure on the North
Korean regime of course North Korea
poses a grave direct threat to all
nations including China and Russia but
what happens when North Korea gets this
capability what if other nations in the
region armed in this way and that's
going to be even more destabilizing and
of course as I mentioned North Korea has
never met a weapon it didn't try to sell
to somebody else so generally you're
saying that you're saying that there's
is is there any way in which the u.s.
can coexist with a nuclear North Korea
anthe I don't think we can tolerate that
risk the world can't tolerate that risk
I mean if North Korea has a nuclear
weapon I mean who is your gonna try to
prevent getting one I mean look at the
behavior of this regime the hostility of
this regime to the to the whole world
President Trump and Secretary Rex
Tillerson have had some high-profile
disagreements does that undermine Rex
Tillerson capability while he's
traveling overseas no the president has
made has made very clear that on North
Korea for example now as now is not the
time to talk and what he means is there
can't be negotiations under these
current conditions that the North has to
show initial steps toward
denuclearization and the reason for this
is previous approaches to negotiating
with North Korea have failed miserably
what the regime does is they enter into
negotiations all the while they continue
these very destructive programs these
talks oftentimes end in a and a week
agreement and then North Korea
immediately violates that agreement the
problem is now that their programs have
advanced so far we don't have time to do
that again and so we can't repeat the
failed pattern of the past I know the
president put out a statement about his
phone call with Russian President Putin
sharing intelligence which has happened
for decades right if we know what
terrorist attack is gonna happen in
another country we try and share that to
prevent the loss of life but the
statement was viewed as unusual by some
experts and last night James clapper who
I know you know well the former Director
of National Intelligence said that Putin
knows how to handle an asset and that's
what he's doing with the president
what do you make of that charge well as
the president made clear in his national
security strategy and in his speech that
he's going to stand up for America no
matter who threatens America and what
he's asked us to do with Russia is
develop an approach that does three
fundamental things first confront
Russia's destabilizing behavior in in
Europe in in the Middle East in our own
country where they use a sophisticated
approach to propaganda and
disinformation where they try to
pulverize communities within democratic
societies and pit them against each
other they use advanced tools cyber
tools and social social media we're
gonna confront that destabilizing
behavior
mr. Clapp what to do with that the
president's being manipulated well it's
just not true with what the president
has asked us to do with Russia though as
well is to make sure we can deter
conflict you see that with the peace
through strength pillar in the national
security strategy but also to try to
find areas of cooperation you mentioned
it up front Russia and the United States
should cooperate on North Korea there's
no way that a nuclear-armed North Korea
is in Russia's interests and the the
president made that clear to President
Putin on the phone call
all right Lieutenant General HR McMaster
Herbert Raymond McMaster we thank you
for joining us it's always good to have
you on this program yes we appreciate
thank you it's great to be with you